and then the other thing too that we we  can't get past is that these envelopes  most of them were empty  what is that we saw this game I don't  know  it was very funny  um on Instagram I believe it was  amazing at first it was the codes to the  nuclear weapons  now it's invisible classified document  um you know it could mean anything I  don't know it could mean that they gave  those documents to Nara and to the FBI  prior as we know which they had done  um if we didn't mean there was nothing  in them it could mean they're invisible  the current Administration I truly don't  know you know what I do know is that we  have seen that this was far-reaching